avec nous embraham qui est directrice
générale de l'Institut du Québec bonsoir
madame RAM bonsoir alors vous avez mené
donc cette étude qui a été commandée
jusqu'à un certain point par la
Fondation du Grand Montréal par
s'entraide du Grand Montréal quelle
était leur objectif pourquoi ils vous
ont donné ce mandat exactement et ce qui
nous ont demandé c'est d'aller au-delà
de la crise du logement dont on parle si
souvent on nous a demandé dans
documenter les différents aspects puis
surtout d'identifier qui était les
personnes les plus affectées et ça c'est
vraiment dans le but de les aider
d'aider tous l'écosystème communautaire
à mieux cibler leurs actions à venir en
aide à ceux qui en ont le plus besoin il
y a plusieurs constats d'ailleurs dans
le dans le document que vous avez
présenté mais c'est intéressant parce
que vous vous n'êtes vous ne vous êtes
pas seulement concentré sur
l'abordabilité linabordabilité vous
parlez du taux d'effort que les ménages
doivent consentir pour se loger ça
représente quoi le taux d'effort madame
alors ces deux concepts qui sont très
liés mais en gros le taux d'effort c'est
la part du revenu total du ménage qui
est consacré à se loger payer son loyer
payer son hypothèque payer les frais
afférents au logement et donc ce qu'on
regarde c'est habituellement on a un
seuil de 30% au-delà de 30% de notre
revenu total qu'on met sur le logement
on considère que le logement commence à
devenir inabordable mais on est allé
plus loin et on est allé regarder
justement comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure ou si les personnes qui
dépensent 50% 80% c'est incroyable en
fait d'ailleurs on a un tableau là qui
va nous aider à comprendre mieux les
données que vous avez présentées dans
cette étude là la part des revenus
montréalais qui consacrent justement
plus de 30% à leurs revenus oui ce qu'on
voit aussi c'est que le taux la part de
ménage qui vivent dans des logements
inabordables est important autant sur
l'île de Montréal que sur la périphérie
on a regardé dans les différents
quartiers puis il y avait des ménages
qui systématiquement étaient les plus
affectés les personnes vivant seule donc
les personnes souvent âgées les
minorités visibles les immigrants les
personnes à faibles revenus dans tous
les quartiers qu'on considérait était
plus proportionnellement plus nombreux à
habiter des logements inabordables
est-ce que puisque vous avez analysé
comme ça plusieurs quartiers et pas que
sur l'île de Montréal vous êtes
intéressé aux grands Montréal donc
Rive-Sud Rive-Nord la périphérie est-ce
qu'il y a des endroits où l'inaborbe
d'habilité est un problème plus criant
alors c'est ce qui est clair aujourd'hui
c'est que c'est le quartier centraux qui
sont les plus touchés on peut penser au
centre-ville de Montréal au plateau mais
également les quartiers centraux à Laval
la comédie sur la Rive-Sud c'est les
quartiers les plus centraux les taux
d'un bordalité sont les plus élevés par
contre si on regarde les tendances on
voit que c'est plutôt dans la périphérie
où les loyers augmentent le plus
rapidement et où il pourrait y avoir
davantage d'enjeux à l'avenir est-ce
qu'on sait pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a un
lien par exemple avec le taux
d'inoccupation d'ailleurs je sais pas si
on va pouvoir le voir vous avez préparé
dans ce document là justement des
données qui nous montrent un lien avec
le taux d'inoccupation là des logements
abordables qu'est-ce qu'on un peu
comprendre des chiffres qu'on voit en ce
moment tout à fait ce qu'on voit c'est
que sur la grande région de Montréal la
part du parc immobilier qui est
disponible pour la location et de 3%. et
on estime habituellement que en dessous
de 3% on est dans une situation de
pénurie de logement mais par contre si
on regarde plus en détail les logements
plus abordables donc par exemple si on
regarde un logement qui sera abordable
pour quelqu'un qui gagne un ménage entre
25 et 36000 dollars comme on le voit
dans le graphique mais là le taux
d'inoccupation donc les logements
disponibles sont beaucoup moins élevés
et donc c'est surtout ce type de ménages
qui font face à des pénuries de logement
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on doit
comprendre de toutes ces données là
est-ce qu'on a un parc locatif qui est
mal adapté ou pour lequel on a pas
suffisamment d'unités d'habitation
carrément quels sont les enjeux qui sont
sous-jacents au chiffre que vous
dévoilez aujourd'hui alors ce qui est
clair c'est que dans surtout dans la
périphérie l'enjeu c'est vraiment la
disponibilité du logement qui est
qui est tout simplement moins moins
disponible on va aussi que les loyers
augmentent rapidement surtout lorsqu'on
est appelé à déménager c'est là qu'on
fait face à des écarts importants
surtout pour des logements plus grands
deux chambres trois chambres pour les
familles et en termes de conséquences
qu'on voit c'est que le fait de faire
face à des enjeux d'abord d'habiter du
logement on est plus propice à habiter
un logement qui est inadéquat donc on a
vu dans les dernières années une
augmentation du nombre de ménages captés
dans des logements trop petits ou encore
qui nécessitaient des réparations
majeures il y a deux choses
intéressantes que vous venez de
mentionner vous dites c'est quand on
déménage que les prix augmentent or le
loyer pour une personne qui habite au
même endroit pendant une longue période
augmente quand même quelle est la
différence entre les deux ce qu'on a
constaté c'est que si on regarde les
logements
occupés donc là où les personnes n'ont
pas déménagé au cours des six dernières
années ça a augmenté de 20%. mais si on
regarde les logements inoccupés donc là
où les locataires ont dû déménager
change de logement on est à 29% en 6
donc les loyers augmentent beaucoup plus
rapidement
lorsque les personnes doivent déménager
et donc doivent faire face à des hausses
de coûts importantes vous mentionnez
également des logements qui ont besoin
de travaux majeurs qui ont besoin
d'amour est-ce que le parc immobilier
qui est vieillissant en ce moment
est inadéquat en ce sens de salubrité
jusqu'à un certain point et même de
temps et vous évoquez des logements plus
grands est-ce qu'il faut l'aménager le
transformer mais ce qui est clair c'est
que les besoins vont changer on voit on
a à la fois des besoins de plus pour des
ménages de plus en plus petits de plus
en plus de personnes qui vivent seules
de plus en plus de personnes âgées donc
on a besoin encore de ces logements plus
petits pour une certaine portion de la
population mais aussi des logements plus
grands pour les familles notamment en
périphérie là où la demande semble
augmenter de manière importante au cours
des dernières années très intéressant
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
madame brame merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]